[Musik]
guten tag
aber mal ehrlich wie gut sind sie
derzeit unsere künstlich stillgelegten
immer gleichen und oft auch schrecklich
einsamen tage tage den so vieles fehlt
wofür sich zu leben lohnt was diese
pandemie erfahrung für unsere tiefsten
ängste die hoffnungen bedeutet was genau
an ihr so verstörend ist und nicht
zuletzt wer oder was uns darin trost
wehren kann
darüber möchte ich heute mit der
philosophin und schriftstellerin thea
dorn sprechen von dort sind sie da ja
ich freue mich dass ich hier bin
mal ehrlich was war denn in den letzten
zwölf monaten der moment wo sie dachten
jetzt bin ich auch dabei den verstand zu
verlieren vielleicht nicht mehr ganz bei
trost zu sein
einen ganz kurzen moment als ich diese
plexiglas zwischen und sprach bin ja
weil das hat natürlich was also wenn
jetzt freundlich sind können wir für
eine bankschalter situation halten etwas
unfreundlich erinnert mich das an die
bilder die wir so aus amerikanischen
knast serien kennen
da fehlt jetzt nur noch dass wir beiden
telefonhörer in der hand hätten und dann
irgendwann mal an die scheibe rankommen
ich habe ihn auch später das vom rat ja
okay also das finde ich ehrlich gesagt
schon eine neue qualität dass man ein
philosophisches gespräch im fernsehen
durch plexiglas schreiben führt
erschüttert mich aber mal ein schritt
zurück heißt es dass sie die
unmittelbarkeit des sozialen interaktion
vermissen dass das ist etwas was ihnen
leben in land erscheint und auch dafür
so erfahren haben unbedingt also das ist
ja noch nicht mal eine sache wo man
sagen kann diese form von von von
austausch auf ein physischer nähe den
anderen physisch erfahren
das ist ja noch nicht mal werd ich
glaube das ist eine archaische
anthropologische konstante dass der
mensch das will und der einsiedler dem
der andere mensch vielleicht so schmeckt
es vielleicht ist sogar sein eigener
körper ein eigener leib so schmeckt das
waren bisher immer randfiguren in der
geschichte das waren welche die entweder
nach einer besonderen heiligkeit streben
oder es war ein kreuz
je nach sicht und dass dieser typus auf
einmal der sagt mir ist alles andere
menschliche leben suspekt weil es
vorrangig nämlich eine wien
leider ist das der gewissermaßen zum
neuen normal typus um mich zu sagen
vielleicht sogar zum ideal wird
ich glaube dass richtet einiges mit
unserem menschenbild an
man könnte ja auch sagen als
philosophierender mensch ist das
geradezu ein geschenk man kann nämlich
nur alleine denken man braucht den
rückzug und den fokus diese zeit ist
eine zeit in der wir sehr sehr viel über
uns lernen und zwar in positiver weise
weil wir alleine sind
das ist alles nicht falsch also das
pathos der distanz wir wissen dass
friedrich nietzsche war ein großer
vertreter dieses pathos der etwas
nachdem vögele fliegen allein ich war
absolut und sie sind schreibender mensch
ich bin schreibender mensch ich würde
sagen wir gehören in dem sinne zu den
privilegierten weil wir könnten unsere
berufe gar nicht ausüben wenn wir nicht
sehr sehr gut alleine sein könnten
als ich meinen letzten sehr großen roman
der fast 500 seiten war geschrieben habe
wohnung und sterblichkeit und
dergleichen geht da hab ich quasi im
privat lockdown gelebt vor fünf jahren
da bin ich teilweise wochenlang nicht
vor die tür weil ich so in der welt von
diesem buch versunken waren auch diese
konzentration braucht weil es nämlich
kein ganz einfacher text war so das war
aber erstens mal eine freiwillige
künstlerische lebens entscheidung ist
mir nicht von außen auferlegt und
trotzdem kommt es mir mit blick auf die
menschen in meinem umfeld die deutlich
erst mal größeres bedürfnis nach
geselligkeit haben kommt es mir sehr
zynisch vor wenn man die eigenen
maßstäbe weil man zufällig zu den
momentan glücklichen gehört die ganz gut
zurechtkommen mit einsamkeit oder mit
alleinsein erstmal die allein seien eben
nicht sofort als einsamkeit empfinden
wenn man jetzt den anderen sagt 'mensch
habt euch mal nicht so guckt mich an das
geht doch eigentlich alles ganz prima
weil in unserer beruf unser zentraler
beruf das schreiben ist sowieso eine
allein um nicht zu sagen einsame
tätigkeit aber nehmen sie die leute im
theater ich habe das in meinem nächsten
umfeld die können ihre berufe nur aus
lügen das ist ein durch und durch
sozialer beruf und die sind jetzt an
allen fronten isoliert also ganz zu
schweigen von der ökonomische wahnsinnig
heiklen situation in der jetzt viele
sind denen fehlt weil das ist ja
teilweise auch deren soziales leben
es ist ja nicht nur das sind nicht nur
kollegen und diese hoffnung dass das auf
uns geworfen sein uns jetzt alle zu
kleinen nietzsches umzudenken macht ganz
ehrlich das skepsis bei freenet eine
elitäre gedanken bewegung aber immerhin
hat es im lok dazu geführt dass er ein
neues buch geschrieben habt trost dass
sich auch ganz intensiv mit dieser
corona erfahrung einer tragischen corona
vorerfahrung auseinandersetzt man könnte
aber auch sagen das ist schon eigentlich
ein entwicklungsziel gebildete menschen
zeichnen sich dadurch aus dass sie mit
sich allein sein können das ist
vielleicht sogar bildung im gespräch mit
sich selbst bleiben können und das ist
genug ist mit sich selbst sein zu können
ja also wenn wir jetzt über
schriftsteller oder philosophen reden da
war ja auch zum beispiel freund
nietzsche immer sehr genau der auch bei
ganz vielen setzen die so steilere
lebens vorschläge wie man muss sich von
zeit zu zeit selber verlieren um sich
dann wieder zu finden also alle diese
tollen ratschläge die einen titel oder
dem leben nie gegeben hat schreibt er
häufig ergänzend dazu wenn man ein
philosoph sein will also sogar er ihm
war bewusst dass die streckung gibt dass
das nicht unbedingt was ist was man und
das ist überhaupt nicht respektiere ich
gemeint wenn ich jetzt sagt das kann man
nicht auch viele übertragen weil also
eine gesellschaft ganz ehrlich die nur
noch aus diesen isolations fähigen
philosophen besteht die kommt auch nicht
mehr sehr weit also das ist mir sehr
nahe und grundsympathisch auch figur und
vielleicht sogar eine stabile figur
aber ich glaube wirklich dass das nicht
als ein gesellschafts ideal für
allgemeiner berg sein kann diese
erfahrung der pandemie birgt ja wie eine
lupe man könnte das auch auf die
einsamkeit beziehen weil es gibt eine
pandemie der einsamkeit in dieser
gesellschaft ein drittel der schweizer
sagen dass sie unter einsamkeit leiden
das sind sehr oft ältere oder alte
menschen aber jetzt natürlich auch die
jungen und sehr jungen menschen die
enisa vereinsamung sind ich meine man
könnte sagen die moderne existenz ist
eine die in die zunehmende vereinsamung
führt und auch das wird durch diese
krone erfahrung erst richtig sichtbar
und spürbar
da kommt ganz viel zusammen also
natürlich könnte man die moderne auch
emanzipations prozesse kann man immer
als den kampf um rückzugsräume
wir erinnern uns an den berühmten satz
von virginia woolf dass die frau eine
frau braucht
zimmer für sich ein zimmer allein das
ist der inbegriff von emanzipation im
grunde ist keines gewinnung genau ich
bin nicht eingebunden ich bin nicht nur
ein rädchen in meinem familiensystem
sondern ich bin ein eigenständiges
individuum das ist ein event das
freiheits potenzial aber natürlich auch
ein isolations potenzial ich habe
persönlich zum beispiel in japan mal die
erfahrung gemacht wo ich einige monate
gelebt habe die konnten das überhaupt
nicht verstehen dass ich gerne alleine
durch die stadt geben
die wollten wir immer begleiter ich
dachte wir sind das jetzt aufpassen oder
was machen die das war einfach nur die
geste dass sie sich nicht vorstellen
konnten
das ist schön höher ist als bei eins zu
sein als mit anderen zu sein
aber wie gesagt alles freiwillig das
nächste ist ja und ich glaube da gibt es
auch im engen zusammenhang vielleicht
hätten wir dieses verordnete alleinsein
seit einem jahr oder viele von und
überhaupt nur aus weil sie eine art von
pseudo nähe pseudo intimität durch die
digitalen durch die neuen medien haben
ich habe mir im letzten monaten oft die
frage gestellt ob die überwältigende
traumblick proxy ist nicht mehr sooo
überwältigend aber immer noch eine
mehrheit auch der deutschen ich weiß
nicht genau wie die zahlen in der
schweiz sind es befürworten dass es
relativ strenge in deutschland sind sie
ja noch wird etwas strenger lockdown
maßnahmen gibt ob das wirklich auch so
wäre wenn unser einziges
kommunikationsinstrumente telefon wäre
also wenn wir nicht ob man das wort aus
hilter ob jetzt dann überhaupt ausleben
und ob man dann nicht noch mal sehr
genauen blick darauf machen muss was
eben doch ein unterschied ist ob man
physisch miteinander in einem raum sitzt
oder ob man eine zoom oder teams oder
was auch immer konferenz auf dem
bildschirm abhält oder facebook oder
skype oder keine ahnung was ich dann
noch alles wobei in diesen digitalen
erfahrung ja offenbar eine starke
ambivalenz im spiel ist dass menschen
sich gerade dadurch vereins abfinden
dass sie soziale zugänge haben in diesen
medien dass sie sehen was andere
menschen tun weil sie alles erleben so
dass viele auf twitter oder facebook
gehen und danach sich um vieles einsamer
vielen als zuvor
also man kann sagen dass es die
krankheit die sich als die therapie
ausgibt und es ist natürlich zum
beispiel ist also die haben das
stichwort die einsamkeit bei den älteren
also
machen wir uns nichts vor wie viele
85-jährige kennen sie die begeisterte
social media nutzer sind nicht so viel
glück
so also das ist auch also die die wir
vermeintlich am dringendsten schützen
wollen die also die über 80-jährigen die
ich kenne deren sozialkontakte haben
sich überwältigend einfach live
abgespielt hatten skatrunden
lesergruppen gesangsvereine alles
mögliche ihre universität des dritten
lebensalters und was sie nicht alles
gemacht haben und das ist durch die
digitalität nicht auffangen war und da
ist glaube ich ein riesiges problem weil
es ist ein unglaublicher entwertung auch
oder ein verdächtig machen der
leiblichkeit was wir erleben und das ist
natürlich wenn man so will ohnehin auch
einer der flucht punkte die in der
technologisch hochgerüsteten spätmoderne
angelegt sind also steht mal ganz am
anfang der leib war manchen religiösen
strömungen stichwort auch christentum
heilig werden schon immer verdächtig und
auf eine komische weise in einer völlig
säkularisierten zeit ist der leib auf
einmal schon wieder verdächtigt weil
eben erst anfällig er kann krank werden
er kann viren sich einfangen und
weitergeben und das ist also ich glaube
wir sehen noch gar nicht ab wie im
moment die auswirkungen sind auf unser
menschen diese fluchtlinien die
kulturellen die sich gerade zeigen
also wir haben schon ermittelt es gibt
es jetzt für verschiedene formen von
einsamkeit sie hat viele gesichter
wir sehen uns mal am beispiel einer
person carola reimann an wie sie
einsamkeit erlebt anhand eines
ausschnittes aus seinem dokumentarfilm
wenn ich jetzt an meine persönliche ein
paar denke dann denke ich an dieses
gefühl das nicht gesehen werden sich
abgeschnitten fühlen eine sehr starke
melancholie und wie einfach nicht dazu
gehören das gefühl dass ich nicht dazu
höre mein thema ist eher dass ich mich
ein sondern in beziehungen mit anderen
menschen früher aber größeren anlässen
hochzeiten zum beispiel
es kann sein wenn ich auf einem konzert
bin und ich habe bestimmt des lieds und
ich spüre irgendwie mich nicht mit
meinen freunden in dem moment verbunden
und ich weiß aber dass hat wenig mit den
freunden zu tun sondern selbst mit
meinem ja anschneiden sehr stark
ausgeprägten bedürfnis nach da bestimmt
nur art von sozialer oder emotionaler
nähe
das kann sich sehr plötzlich bekommen
und ich weiß aber auch dass geht wieder
und zu meiner geschichte glaube ich
gehört dieses gefühl der eindruck halt
sehr stark dazu für mich glaube ich so
ein einschneidendes erlebnis war eine
sehr schwere krankheit als ich 14 war
hat im gehirn tumor da war relativ lange
zeit nicht klar ob ich diesen tumor
überlebe mit mehr hat damals keiner
und für mich war einfach dass das
schlimmste dass alle meine freunde mich
nicht besuchen durften weil ihm gesagt
worden ist ich werde sterben und meine
freunde wollten wie ich halt nicht in
den sterbeprozess sehen und da habe ich
mich sehr sehr einsam gefühlt
und zwar habe ich eigentlich so ein
schwarzes großes loch gesehen also
diesen abgrund in den ich eigentlich
hineinfallen nicht keiner hält was mir
sehr zu gute kommt als selbständige ist
wirklich sehr gerne alleine arbeiten
wenn ich dann irgendwie lust habe auch
jugendcafé dann gehe ich eben im café
liest zeitung und das genieße ich dann
auch sehr ich glaube ihm allein sein ist
eine ganz wichtige prophylaxe gegen
einsamkeit dabei wenn ich lerne bewusst
alleine zu sein dass ich dann auch
weniger an mich einsam fühle
das war ein ausschnitt aus dem dokfilm
tabu einsamkeit geschichten über das
alleinsein den ganzen filmen können sie
am kommenden donnerstag um 20 5 auf sf 1
sehen
klingt ja eigentlich fast wie ein
trainingslager das alleinsein als
prophylaxe für die einsamkeit aber man
hat auch in diesem film gesehen da jetzt
ein großes schwarzes loch und das hat
auch was mit dem tod zu tun der eine
form der ultimativen vereinsamung ja
also ich muss gestehen dass mich wenn
ich ihr zu hören dass mich das wirklich
sehr an fast also auch weil ich mich
natürlich sofort frage 'was zum teufel
haben sich eltern oder ich weiß ja nicht
genau wie es war das bleibt jetzt in dem
ausschnitt zumindest offen wer damals
auf diese idee gekommen sein mag zu
sagen oder stirbt vielleicht eine junge
frau ein mädchen und weil die quasi ja
schon so ein bisschen nicht mehr bei den
lebenden ist sollen dann die freunde das
ist ja wie als ob der tod als solcher
also wenn es ein tumor den war das ist
nun garantiert keine infektionskrankheit
wo es überhaupt keinen grund gibt zu
sagen da darf keinen besuch mehr kommen
und offensichtlich hatte sie ja das
bedürfnis
ich weiß es gibt schwer kranke menschen
oder sterbenskranke menschen die wollen
auch alleine sein das gibt es natürlich
auch aber wenn man dieser frau zu gehört
gab es ja offensichtlich das dringende
bedürfnis und die artikuliert dass er
selber das gefühl da ist irgendwas was
mich hält und das zu verwehren weil der
tod offensichtlich so tabuisiert ist und
so verdrängt werden soll dass man das
anscheinend für unzumutbar hält das
andere junge menschen mit einer
schwerkranken jungen frau konfrontiert
werden
das macht mich wirklich fassungslos so
diese fassungslosigkeit steht ja
eigentlich auch am ausgang ihres buches
trost brief an maxwell die
ausgangssituation ist eine der doppelten
man kann sagen tödlichen vereinsamen es
geht darum dass eine frau briefe an
ihren philosophischen lehrer schreibt
und die mutter dieser frau sanja cupid
19 verstorben ohne dass man voneinander
hätte abschied nehmen können und
eigentlich geht es um zwei tragisch
verwerfung das allein sterben der mutter
die völlig isoliert aus dem leben geht
und die erfahrungen der tochter die auch
allein ist mit ihrem schmerz man kann
sagen zwei zentrale aspekte der
vereinsamung genau und die tragödie
entsteht weil diese tochter ja am anfang
also die ist eine große befürworterin
maximaler vorsicht im umgang mit dieser
pandemie also die erzählung über die
letzten tage im leben der mutter die
diese tochter in den briefen neben dem
max schreibt beginnt damit dass sie sagt
diese verdammte mutter die sich für
unsterblichen hat mich allein gehört
genau ich habe ihr gesagt motiv nicht
nach italien das ist gefährlich das land
ist schon fast im ausnahmezustand und
mutter sagt aber schon bis den grippe
kommt lassen wir doch hier nicht meine
italien pläne also die mutter war eine
sehr umtriebige erfolgreiche
schauspieler agentin hatte auch freunde
die in italien leben
ist offensichtlich großer caravaggio fan
wollte unbedingt mal die uffizien solaer
erleben wie sie leben in vollen zügen
genießen so genau also dass generation
typ ische also die dame eben über 80
generation typische deutsche widder
italiensehnsucht gefühl und die dachte
toll so leer erheblich italien wieder
natürlich war ich da hin und dann
passiert das wo die tochter erst mal
sagt um gott deswegen werde die mutter
nur vorsichtiger gewesen und dann
schnappt aber die tragödie zu weil die
tochter fest stellt genau das was sie an
der front fordern und verteidigen müsste
nämlich dass die leute sich isolieren
dass sie maximal vorsichtig sind dass
sie nicht mehr solche dummheiten machen
wie ihre mutter sie gemacht hat das
brocki rein dass sie mit ihrer ganzen
verzweiflung ihrem schmerz aller händler
sitzt einsam ist und damit ist die
tragödie
da weil es gibt kein klare welche seite
richtiger ist
ich denke wirklich dass eine szene in
der sich extrem viele telematische
situationen dieser zeit aber nicht nur
der pandemie zeit verdichten fängt schon
damit an das kennen wir ja beide aus
unserer generation dass sich das
beratungs verhältnis von eltern und
kindern irgendwann umkehrt dass man
derjenige ist ich höre dass ganz oft
derzeit von freunden wir knien unsere
eltern vernünftig zu sein und auf einmal
bewegen die sich wie teenager und sagen
ach lass mal das ist nicht so schlimm
lasst mich doch mal eben eine geradezu
paradox verdrehung einer situation die
man als kind selbst erlebt hat
ja was ist ein interessanter punkt also
ich mache auch die erfahrung dass in
meinem persönlichen umfeld sehr viele
von denen die 80 plus sind also
tatsächlich zu dem risiko bis hoch
risikogruppen gehören entspannter
umgehen
mit der pandemie als manch einer in
unsere generation so sagen wir mal ganz
grob gesagt zwischen 40 und 60 die wir
ein bisschen risiko haben aber doch wenn
wir die kirche im dorf lassen ein sehr
überschaubares risiko also ganz anders
als die die 80 plus sind und also
entweder hat es damit zu tun dass also
die die lebensweisen von denen würde ich
sagen ja
die wissen dass sie mit 80 dem tod nicht
mehr ganz ganz fern sind haben sich mit
gedanken schuld familiaris würden dieser
es wäre meine hoffnung sagen wir mal so
mir kommt es umgekehrt ich kenne auch
andere ich kenne auch weit über
80-jährige die sagen ich will an diesen
verdammten tod überhaupt nicht denken
dieser tod geht mich nichts an
ich respektiere diese haltung unbedingt
weil ich glaube es verbietet dich
sowieso in diesem ganzen thema um tod
also man darf auch keinen menschen
vorschriften machen wollen wie er mit
dem tod umzugehen hat wenn ich glaube
jede art von von doktrinärer auftreten
verbietet sich aus dem ganz einfachen
grund dass ich auch selber biografisch
ist das einzige sterben was ich bisher
aus nächster nähe erlebt habe das meiner
mutter alles was ich vorher vermutet
hätte wie das ablaufen würde vollkommen
falsch aus dieser zeit habe ich auch die
lehrer für mich selber mitgenommen dass
ich sage ich habe keine ahnung wer oder
was ich werde wenn ich denn wirklich im
einzugsbereich des todes bin also
deshalb dass vorne weg geschickt
trotzdem kommt es mir wenn ich jetzt
heute 50-jährige aufs sterben und auf
den tod gucke es kommt mir merkwürdig
vor
wenn man mit 80 immer noch die haltung
hat zu sagen nein kommt dieser tod ist
doch da reden wir jetzt nicht darüber
das ist ganz weit weg
das geht mich nichts an eine seltsame
form der unreife könnte man sagen wenn
etwas so unmittelbar im raum steht und
auch an steht ja also nur kommt dann und
das ist ja auch eines der probleme mit
denen sich meine johanna so diese
hauptfigur im roman man muss sagen die
situation die sie schildern ist keine
selbst erlebte sondern eine fiktive die
sie aber auch ihr gefällt als solche
wahrgenommen habe ich meine dieses
abschieds lose statt
ich hab das umgekehrte erlebt also ich
meine mutter ist schon seit 13 jahren
tot und ich saß die letzten tage und
stunden also ich habe dieses sterben und
was sterben ist was kein mensch
der es noch nicht erlebt habe das ist
das erste was ich da gelernt habe und
ich habe gelernt und deshalb habe ich
wahrscheinlich so sensibel reagiert auf
auch auf diesen beitrag jetzt ich habe
gelernt dass das einzige was hilft ist
physische nähe also diese wir haben ja
vielleicht so komische ideen im kopf wie
es gibt eben also auch abschied nehmen
ist schon finde ich ein schwieriger
begriff weil das klingt so nach wir
machen jetzt um eine große szene und wir
hätten da irgendwelche rituale gar und
da kommt es so noch mal zur großen
aussprache oder was man da immer noch im
kopf haben kann mag es geben aus der
erfahrung die ich gemacht habe kann ich
sagen es alles nicht der punkt der
einzige punkt um den es geht ist da sein
und genau das was die frauen den beitrag
beschrieben hat versuchen das gefühl zu
geben du bist gehalten
das ist natürlich hoch fragwürdig weil
ist das also wenn ein mensch dann
wirklich stirbt ich weiß werden nie
erfahren ob ich meiner mutter trost war
indem ich sie auch in den letzten
stunden ihres lebens halten konnte und
man muss ja oft sagen sind diese
menschen ich habe das auch so erlebt wie
sind dann auch nicht mehr ganz bei sich
selbst
schmerzmittel und der morphin ist ein
seltsamer bewusst zustand deshalb
präsenten von dem man nicht mehr sagen
kann dass man überhaupt noch abschied
nimmt das ist dann nur noch hand halten
und das ist genau der punkt deshalb also
das war glaube ich wenn sie mich fragen
moment zorn gipfel in dieser pandemie
war mein traum gipfel erreicht als ich
hörte dass jetzt krankenhäuser jahr
verstärkt tablets anschaffen wollen
damit sterben decker tablet von ihren
angehörigen abschied nehmen kann also
das war so ein kurzer moment wo ich
dachte jetzt entdecke ich so ein
antigone terrorismus potenzial in mir
weil gesagt habt ihr jemals erlebt was
sterben reisen also diese idee man hätte
meiner sterbenden mutter die eben auch
wieder an krebs gestorben die die
letzten tage nicht mehr wirklich
ansprechbar ihres lebens zu sagen kommen
wir halten der jetzt mal irgendein
tablet in was an die dann zum teufel
damit man gut man kann sagen es ist eine
schwierige situation und man will etwas
tun vielleicht ist es aktionismus
vielleicht ist es einfach nur ausdruck
einer hilflosigkeit aber was sie jetzt
gesagt haben das sind jetzt für mich
zwei sehr wichtige stichworte einmal der
zorn und einmal ein tragisches moment
haben wir mal mit dem zorn an diese
johanna
der heldin ist unglaublich zornig sie
weiß ich aber auch in ihrem zorn als
irrational und diese spannung entsteht
einfach dadurch dass sie in dieser
situation etwas wahrnimmt niemand ist
wirklich schuld sie versteht die
anforderungen des krankenhauses sie
versteht die spezielle situation der
pandemie und doch bleibt sie in ihrem
gefühlsleben den skandal dass der
skandal ist präsent wie kann das einfach
nicht annehmen das ist so ist und jetzt
kann man sagen eine situation in der
jeder sich an die regeln die wir alle
für begründbar halten gehalten hat und
die trotzdem unglaublich schmerz erzeugt
sie nennt man mit einem alten wort
tragisch das ist doch eigentlich etwas
was ich glaube in dieser ganzen pandemie
diskussion immer ein bisschen wegfällt
jeder versucht zu sagen ja wir haben
eine vernünftige lösung und da eine
vernünftige lösung aber dass da ein
tragischer abgrund bleibt das wird kaum
gesprochen
unbedingt und das war genau der grund
warum ich zu diesem thema eben keinen
philosophischen essays oder gar ein
politisches pamphlet oder dergleichen
geschrieben hat sondern weshalb ich
diese literarische ausgangssituation
auch brauchte weil ich den eindruck habe
wir schaffen ein mensen und versöhnten
rest durch diesen diskurs zu sagen jetzt
reicht s euch mal zusammen habt euch mal
nicht so ist doch alles vernünftig und
nicht zu begreifen was da eben an
starken emotionen wie verzweiflung oder
wie zorn oder auch wie hast also die
emotionen die hochgefährlich sind für
eine gesellschaft wie die im verborgenen
wachsen also bei manchen werden sie dann
eher auto aggressiv oder wenden sich
gegen sie selbst dann gibt er depression
sad iges phänomen ihre helden geht durch
alle fahren wie kann alles genau und ist
war und das merkte ich selber was das
für eine immense entlastung auch für
mich war zu sagen in einem alltag bin
ich natürlich auch eine vorbildlich
vernünftige bürgerin
aber so wie diese johanna das kann ich
mich hinsetzen und richtig loslegen mir
meinen ganzen groll und den ganzen mist
von der seele schreibt heiliger furor
kann man sich dann faltet und das halte
ich zum beispiel für ein riesiges
problem dass wir das momentan und das
geht ja nicht erst seit corona los da
haben wir schon seit längerem ein
neben nicht mehr auseinander gehalten
bekommen ich bin eine strikte gegnerin
von allen versuchen wir es in
deutschland etwa einer afd versucht ich
weiß nicht wie das die entsprechenden
schweizer partei handhabung
populistisches muster das in allen
nationen aber auch sehr dezent wir
darauf setzen den zorn in folge hoch zu
halten also die dann auch mit einer
fragwürdigen übersetzung vom ilias
beginnen anfangen zu operieren zu sagen
angeblich sei das ganze abendland ja
darauf gebaut ist der zorn besungen wird
der zorn des achilles ja da muss man
dann in sehr komplizierte diskussionen
einsteigen ob das wirklich mit dem
riemen des zorns sehen anfängt oder
beschreibe mir den zorn auch mit seinen
negativen das ist ein ganz dramatisch
aber sie würden sagen der unversehrte
rest der bleiben muss der wirt
konzipiert von rechtspopulisten im sinne
von genau einer schlechten politischen
gefühl und die gegenseite sozusagen die
guten die sagen dieser zorn darf
überhaupt nicht vorkommen jeder der
zornig ist ist schon mit einem bein
entweder in dem rechtspopulismus oder in
irgendwelchen obskuren corona leutner
demo zusammenhängen
das halte ich für grundfalsch also das
berührt auch mein verständnis von kunst
sehen kern also für mich ist die kunst
einst einer der der der ideal der ideale
raum nachgerade wo diese emotionen ihren
raum haben dürfen also gute alte
katharsis theorie irgendwo muss es raus
diese starken emotionen
sie dürfen politisch instrumentalisiert
brandgefährlich sie völlig tabuisieren
wie wir es momentan eher tun genauso
brandgefährlich weil die sind ja nicht
weg die werden ja nur das ist wie so ein
topf in dem zu viel druck ist da kann
man eine weile den deckel drauf halten
aber man riskiert dass das ding
irgendwann richtig explodiert und
deshalb glaube ich wir brauchen solche
räume wir brauchen musik wir brauchen
literatur bräuchten theater was im
augenblick gar nicht ein großer jahr das
inszeniert wird das aber meine also
meine größte leidenschaft als ich die
kunst so richtig für mich entdeckte war
die opernsängerin werden genau ich habe
auch eine gesangsausbildung gemacht also
und es gab wirklich auch mich erinnere
früher als teenager ist man ja
eigentlich nur verzweifelt dann habe ich
mich in die aula der schule gestellt und
habe
welche verdi arien oder sogar wackener
geschmettert oder elektra wenn ich auf
meine mutter richtig frau nicht wahr
elektra von richard strauss aufgedreht
und danach bin ich nicht raus und hab
meine mutter umgebracht sondern danach
ging es wieder
sie haben sich ja gereinigt dadurch ich
nehme zwei dinge mit einmal wenn wir
trost suchen dieser verzweiflung ist das
medium der kunst ein plausibler und
andererseits die art und weise wie kunst
mit telematischen situation umgeht ist
vielleicht die einzigartig warte das
sind situationen aus denen man sich
nicht heraus vernünftigen kann und
deswegen müssen wir sie in ihre
schwierigkeit beschreiben und sie
entzieht sich diesem wir haben ja also
auch wenn uns der angelsächsische
utilitarismus wo man eine moralisch
richtige handlung quasi mit dem
rechenschieber jetzt etwas karikaturhaft
gesagt in ihren folgen genau wo man sagt
also okay hier leiten so und so viel
erleiden so und so viel dann machen wir
eine ordentliche rechnung unterm strich
kommt raus hier wird unterm strich ein
bisschen weniger gelitten wenn wir den
handlungs weg und schon ist die tragödie
aufgelöst und wir haben die richtige
entscheidung
da reagieren wir sehr sehr sensibel in
kontinentaleuropa wenn das mit abwägung
wer kriegt medizinische versorgung also
klassische gitarrist findet rasch zum
beispiel die frage wem kann man unter
knappen bedingungen noch
intensivmedizinisch betreut wird ein
jubiläumsangebot der vernunft ein
militarist kann das sauber ausrechnen
wenn denn die zahlen stimmen mit denen
errechnet und sagen hier richtige lösung
wir die wir eher aus pflicht ethik
kontexten der unternehmerischen
kontexten in kontinentaleuropa kommen
wird empfinden das natürlich ganz anders
wo wir sagen aber es gibt dieses gebot
nicht sterben zu lassen und das kann man
jetzt nicht einfach auflösen
unbedingt naja das deshalb stockte mir
haben es gemerkt der ersatz weil wir
wissen dass beide von immanuel kant
unterscheidet aus guten grund zwischen
vollkommenen und unvollkommenen
pflichten und es gibt gute gründe dafür
zu sagen dass die pflicht zu helfen eben
keine vollkommene ist weil sie einen
fürchterlichen aporien führt wenn man
sie verabsolutiert und ich vermute mal
dass ein
genau da stehen wir jetzt in dieser
pandemie
dass die verabsolutierung dass wir leute
nicht an infektionskrankheiten wie kobe
19 es ist sterben lassen natürlich zu
diesen ganzen katalog an rigorosen
maßnahmen führt den wir jetzt erleben
und das ist aus meiner sicht die nächste
tragische situation in der wir sind aber
auch nicht erinnern weil das ist schon
ein unglaublich wichtiger punkt sie
sprachen es gibt eine art politisches
versagen in der ansprache und auch in
dem signal geben dass wir diese
telematische situation als solche
erkennen und adressieren man kann aber
auch sagen die philosophen zunft selbst
ist teil des problems der philosoph
bernard williams zum beispiel der sich
sehr viel mit tragisch praktischen
dingen und den griechen auseinander
gesetzt hat sagt nein die moderne
moralphilosophie hat das gefühl verloren
dass es tragik gibt sie sagt uns
einerseits mit note touristen ich gebe
euch eine art von form in der wir
vernünftig handeln können auch der
kanzler hat ein mittel das eigene
gewissen zumindest rein zu halten wenn
er sich an maxim hält und dann sagt man
bei der ethischen existenz geht es darum
die tragische situation als tragische zu
formulieren zu erkennen und zu sagen
hier gibt es keine vernünftige lösung
was ich sagen will ich habe oft das
gefühl dass öffentlich sprechen die
philosophen über kuchen gar nicht bereit
sind die trage ebenfalls anzuerkennen
sondern sich da so aus vernünftigen mit
der einen oder anderen methode
es ist also da müssen wir ganz tief in
die philosophiegeschichte gehen der
verlust des tragischen wenn man so will
setzt mit dem monotheismus ein der
monotheismus war das große versprechen
ggg das für ein tolles prinzipiell
tolles das große versprechen aus dieser
griechisch antiken heidnischen
tragischen weltsicht rauszukommen
kurz zusammengefasst also wenn man ein
götterhimmel hat der zerklüftete wo es
einen merkwürdig der eine viele kräfte
kräfte und mehr mensch ist irgendwie
spielball
weil du weißt halt nie welcher gott
bekriegt gerade wenig welches kräftefeld
gerate ich da als armes menschlein oder
einer der mich eben noch besonders
geliebt hat von den göttern ganz
schwierig weil deshalb hast mich dann
der andere umso mehr also diese ganzen
antiken tragödien geschichten die wir
kennen und das führt aber zu diesem
beunruhigenden zustand dass man eben
nicht den eindruck hat am schluss etwas
einfaches dar
sondern es hat es verstärkt auch ein
gefühl das ausgesetzt sein was der
menschen nicht gerne hat was wir sehr
stark haben was wir moment genau und was
wir uns mit aller macht versuchen vom
leibe zu halten und der monotheismus war
das große versprechen
ich sage es jetzt sehr einfach jetzt
wird einfach schluss mit dieser
zerklüftet schluss mit ebendiesem
polytheismus jetzt gibt es hier den
einen gott und wenn du machst was der
eine gott will dann hast du eine chance
auf den weg ins himmelreich sieht sehr
sehr groß ist das patentrezept als
erstes und das ist natürlich für alle
kulturen die stark im bannkreis eines
monotheismus stehen und geprägt und
geformt und gebildet wurden
die tun sich strukturell schwer mit
dieser eher klassisch griechisch
tragischen weltsicht das geht ja schon
in der antike los also ein philosoph
platon war einer der ersten der massiv
versucht hat mit diesem mit diesem chaos
da oben aufzuräumen und zu sagen ich
kann es gibt einen weg wie wir uns so
immunisieren können gegen dieses
schicksal was uns von allen seiten um
die ohren pfeift mit seinen pfeilen
da geht es schon los also da ist dann
das christentum tatsächlich bereits
massiv angelegt würde ich sagen aber das
ist genau das problem dass der mensch
das nicht gut aus hängt dieses gefühl
dass er einem zerklüfteten himmel
ausgesetzt ist und deshalb will er ihn
sich einfacher machen und das führt halt
zu einer rigorosität die dann eben auch
permanent behauptet werden muss weil ich
würde sagen die welt ist nicht so also
ich glaube mit verlaub da diese
immunisierung irgendwie so laube in dem
sinne dass in dieser tragisch
griechischen sicht ein höherer gehetzt
sinn steckt als in der idee das ist das
eine große prinzip gibt dass wenn uns
das zerklüftet erscheint haben wir bloß
noch nicht dass eine große prinzip
verstanden so dann liegt es daran dass
und so ein bisschen wird ja auch im
augenblick auch wieder dass man sagt
naja die die jetzt im augenblick andere
wege vorschlagen wie man mit dieser
pandemie umgehen könnte oder die sonst
wie andere meinungen vertreten
die haben ja noch nicht richtig
durchschaut wie die vernunft aus sieht
man könnte natürlich auch sagen weil ihr
buch ja trost reist und sie in
10 ihren das ja auch sehr bewusst und
sehr kunstvoll diese annahme des
tragischen tröstet auch überhaupt nicht
das ist ja wie zu sagen ich sage es mal
sehr sehr offen anspricht
shit happens naja was soll man machen es
passiert eben solche situationen gibt es
die johanna ist ja jemand der genau
gegen dieses angebot ebenso rebelliert
die auch darin kein trost finden kann
eigentlich trostlos bleibt in allen
angeboten die man gemacht
na ja sie wird den schluss des buches
nicht verraten ich würde schon sagen
dass sie eine entwicklung von ihrem zorn
dem sie am anfang ja auch nachgerade
besingt plus eben darüber dass ihr
selber dieser zorn nicht ganz geheuer
ist findet sie glaube ich schon
ein weg das ist wenn sie so wollen auch
durchaus ein entwicklungsroman nicht in
dem sinne dass es am schluss dann
irgendeine kleine rezept liste gibt mit
trost 1 bis 5 das wäre sicher falsch
aber ich glaube schon durch die tatsache
was artikulieren zu dürfen also
vielleicht müssen wir auch unsere
erwartungen dass der trost so irgendwie
mit lieferservice bestellbar ist liegt
glaube ich schon der ganze große fehler
drin also wenn ich mich jetzt auch
selber befrage also als die idee zum
buch entstand über trust habe ich am
anfang auch gedacht super ich schreibe
essay oder noch vermessene hre idee ich
schreib so eine art neos durch ein trost
brief war ja ein beliebtes genre vor
allem seneca hat wild trost brief
hinterher gegen rom geschickt ich
schreibe an einen lock down
verzweifelten menschen ein trost brief
warum der nicht verzweifeln soll
privates projekt ja so angefangen zu
schreiben und merke ich glaub mir kein
wort
weil ich viel zu viele fragen habe weil
ich eben nicht nur sagen kann jetzt pass
mal auf es so und dann ist es so und
wenn du dich ein bisschen entspannt ist
es überhaupt sowieso kein problem mehr
und ich sagte nein da gibt es in mir
sind so viele fragen und widerstreitende
kräfte ich kann nur die adressatin von
so einem brief sein beim schreiben oder
ich kann nur eine adressatin erfinden
beim schreiben und braucht aber
natürlich unbedingt dieses gegenüber
also deshalb ich bin immer eine ganz
große anhängerin dass man in literatur
nicht nur in theaterstücken auch in
prosatexten ein kraftfeld maximal
aufspannen deshalb eben diese erstmal
ganz und gar und stoische johanna und
deshalb als ihr gegenüber dieser über
frische max auf einer griechischen insel
fast gottgleich entfernt da und zu mal
eine postkarte schicken
aber es gibt ja in diesem buch sehr
viele witzige gewitzte und auch tiefer
einzeiler und einer geht über die story
und sie sagten ich hoffe ich zitiere ist
richtig die store ist nichts anderes als
die kunst sich objektive probleme
subjektiv am arsch vorbei gehen zu
lassen das ist das zitat und da ist ja
auch etwas dran als ob man sich als
subjekt aus dieser welt heraus ziehen
könnte und für sich ein privat frieden
mit der existenz schließt das geht ja
auch noch wie früher also da landen wir
tatsächlich aber auch schon bei platon
also das sind diese ganzen versuche das
diesseitige physische da haben wir
wieder das motiv das physische leibliche
leben wird diskreditiert weil es eben
dieses anfällige ist das kann dir vom
schicksal alles genommen werden deshalb
ist der ja erst mal gar nicht blöde
gedanken trick was hat denn der mensch
was ihm nicht genommen werden kann wo
ist denn der kern der so immunisiert
dass die ganzen schicksalsschläge ihm
nichts anhaben können und das ist
entweder die eigene moralische
vorzüglichkeit also nach dem motto zu
sagen ich habe zwar das schlimmste
erlebt was man steht das schicksal mir
antun kann
aber ich bin ein aufrechter und komisch
gehalten gelaufen wird nicht nur
geblieben also haltung und natürlich der
nächste bereich seele geist nennen wir
es wollen das ist glaube ich der letzten
endes auch relativ austauschbar wenn man
es etwas gröber betrachtet zu sagen und
dann wird halt wieder schwierig weil das
ist ja auch bei platon massiv angelegt
so ganz ohne jenseits konzept kommt der
natürlich auch nicht über die runden
weil er sagt diese seele wird in
irgendwelche serien wohnungen eingehen
und das ist wahrscheinlich viel toller
in so einer seelen wohnung als egal wie
privilegiert man in athen als bürger
waren wohnung ist sicher noch toller
dann also wenn ich das wirklich glaube
dann ist es natürlich auch sehr viel
leichter zu sagen kommen was soll dieses
ganze zeug hier auf erden wo ich eben
krankheiten habe wo ich ungerecht
behandelt werde wo mir alle möglichen
schicksalsschläge freunde sterben
familie kommt mir abhanden
wenn ich sage ja meine eigentliche
existenz in der seelen wohnung fängt
noch an
dann kann ich das relativ leicht
wegwischen
das ist auch eine schwierige dialekte
jeder auf die wertung das jenseits ist
eine abwertung des diesseits jenseits
geht ja auch
länger jaja es idealerweise sollte das
ja bis das weiß man nicht so genau dass
schwieriges konzept der ewigkeit aber
ich bin auch nicht ganz einverstanden
mit ihrer platte bedeutung weil es gibt
ja eine andere person in glarus werk
nämlich sokratis denn durchaus ein
leiblicher ein sehr diesseitige ein
zugewandter mensch ist und er hat sogar
ein rezept dafür wie man das
unchristliche tröster macht zb den
prozess des sterbens es gibt eine
postkarte in ihrem buch das zeigt den
sterbenden zum tode verurteilten so hat
das und das ist die gegen situation zum
kabel sterben im hospital ein
begleitetes ein inszeniertes sterben bis
zum letzten wort unter freunden
das soll doch auch eine form von trost
sein können bis zur letzten minute mit
anderen das zu tun was einem leben trägt
ja also das wird dieser johanna erst
beim betrachten also sie kann mit diesem
bild erstmal doch gar nicht richtig was
anfangen also dieser max hat ihr zuvor
eine eg ist ansicht und dann schickt er
ihren perugino mit heiliger maria und
zwei heiligen das findet sie alles ganz
im osten sind so ein bisschen rätsel die
johanna zum denken bringen soll ein
orakel instagram oder also ja wenn du
heutzutage das orakel sich auf instagram
eine seite hätte banken richtig die sau
raus und sie freut sich ein bisschen
weil der maler sattel wieder fit ist den
sie prinzipiell sehr verehrt also mehr
zumindest als diese heiligen maler und
dann kann sie aber damit nichts anfangen
und dann zerlegt ist die eines macht sie
guckt sich diese karte eben immer und
immer wieder an
als ihr genau dass klar wird was sie
jetzt beschrieben haben dass das
natürlich eigentlich die komplette gegen
szene zudem ist wie ihre mutter
gestorben ist also da eben der ist und
seinen jüngern von seinen schülern
umringt
da liegt auch irgendwo das hat
allerdings wohl eher jacques louis david
ihm spendiert denn das ist immer
allerlei herum also sogar sokrates der
kein großer musikfreund das teilt er mit
seinem team auch immer erfinder platon
kein ganz großer freund der musik auf
einmal fängt der in seinen letzten
nächten also hat er immer das kommt auch
im fall drohen in dem entsprechenden
dialog vor wisst ihr wo er seine stimme
diamond der männer sagte lukas treiber
musik also worauf dann das beten
dass der musiktreibenden sokratis
vielleicht die antwort auf alle fragen
sein könnte wenn sokratis plötzlich auch
noch die musik die kunst quasi das
dionysische für sich entdeckt das ist
natürlich dass es unglaublich was man
aus so einem billig dann alles und ich
würde sagen das ist ganz ehrlich das ist
eine wahnsinnig tröstliche todes
vorstellung die hat aber natürlich einen
unglaublichen preis weil vergessen wir
nicht welche situationen das ist der
mann ist völlig zu unrecht zum tode
verurteilt wir wenn wir heute auf das
gucken und das ist genau die ambivalenz
von johanna die sagten ja jetzt moment
mal also wieso kapituliert den der vor
seinem völlig ungerechten tod der müsste
doch eigentlich erst mal einen solchen
skandal daraus machen dass er zu unrecht
zum tode verurteilt ist oder unter
fadenscheinigen gründen
interessanterweise haben die gründe ja
durchaus auch eine infektion rhetoriker
wurde nämlich die jugend an schwierigen
gewissermaßen interessieren mit gedanken
die die besser nicht haben sollte also
zu sagen hier und das hält ja auch
jacques louis david in dem bild fest
meine lieben schüler jetzt heutigen
nicht meinen sterbe kerker voll weil
eigentlich ist nichts schlimmes passiert
also erstens glaubt auch sokrates und
diese seelen wohnung aber es weiter
ich gehe stolz erhobenen hauptes aus dem
leben
ich sterbe ungefähr so wie ich immer
sterben wollte
das heißt er akzeptiert erst also er ist
keiner der sagt der tod muss um jeden
preis hinausgezögert werden was aber
unsere grundhaltung ich bei so einer
gewissen sagen wir mal eine gewisse
risikobereitschaft für das zu sterben
was man für richtig hält das ist ja auch
eine frau von mut dass armut das ist in
einer reihe ist nein das würde ich
tatsächlich das ist ein heroischer tod
der uns hier gezeigt wird
da bist du kann ist richtig option mehr
es gibt aber vor allem gibt es eine
lebendige option für viele menschen auch
für ihre johanna nicht mehr
das ist der lebendige glaube an die
unsterblichkeit der seele es gibt ja
diesen großen satz wenn gott nicht
existiert ist alles erlaubt man könnte
ihn vielleicht auch um formulieren wenn
die seele nicht unsterblich ist gibt es
keinen trost
es gibt dann keinen trost gegen den tod
das ist möglich also dieses fundamentale
gefühl und es steckt interessanterweise
oder im deutschen wort trost auch drin
halten sein also ich denke tatsächlich
dass das der wichtigste neben begriff
zum trost ist ist das gefühl dass
gehalten science und deshalb können
gläubige christen leben ein zu denen ich
nicht gehöre aber die leben ja in dem
gefühl dieses ich kann nicht tiefer
fallen als in gottes hand da ist einer
der mich hält auch in tiefster nacht und
das ist natürlich ein immenser trost
wenn man denen abrufen kann oder wenn
der einen tatsächlich durchs leben trägt
die frage ist wo nehmen die agnostiker
oder gar atheisten können die überhaupt
sowas wie eben einen trost finden und da
kommt man auch wieder auf eine sokrates
zähne zu sagen ein sinnvoller tod können
also das gefühl ich verweise nicht
einfach nur oder fallen
stracks tod um sondern mein tod ergibt
einen sinn
aber damit tun wir uns eben auch
wahnsinnig schwer weil die typischen
heroischen tode
also ganz ehrlich würden wir heute
jemanden also was wäre das ideal wo wir
sagen würden
der ist ein sokratis vergleichbaren
heldentod gestorben ich würde zum
beispiel sagen dass das was herr navalny
gerade getan hat das kommt der sache
nach
das ist ein heroisches todes bewusstsein
für etwas zu sterben das größer ist als
man selbst und sehenden auges in den tod
zu gehen für etwas an das man glaubt
unbedingt und das ist aber doch
interessant dass wir das dem
applaudieren wir aber halten wir
außerdem nackten biologischen überleben
gerade irgendeinen wert so massiv
dagegen hoch also wenn es ein anderer
tut aus der ferne gewissermaßen sagen
wir das ist toll wie der für freiheit
und gegen ein diktatorisches kann man
nicht in einer gewissen weise sagen dass
wir gerade vor dem ich glaube ich ein
begriff den sloterdijk mal geprägt hat
vor dem natur terrorismus den dieses
virus darstellt dass wir vor dem
kapitulieren also es eine sehr
gefährliche situation oder auch wirklich
eine bedeutung weil das heißt ja
implizit wer sich in dieses vernunft
regiment das unvollkommen ist in vieler
weise ein findet ist ein bisschen auch
ein feigling
nein das ist also
das gab es geht hier nicht um schuld
zuschreibung oder um tugenden
zuschreibung ich glaube es geht darum zu
begreifen was also welche werte halten
wir gerade am höchsten und welche
stellen wir in die zweite linie
gewissermaßen zurück und wenn man sich
eben anschaut wie über ein fallender
wein ihm berichtet wird ist es sehr klar
dass man sagt also gegen einen solchen
despoten wie putin muss man mutig
auftreten
dahinter steckt natürlich das konzept
das man die hoffnung hat dass man durch
derlei mutige individuen die sich ihm
entgegenstellen vielleicht dieses system
zum einbruch bringt oder in sondern
grausamkeit maskiert genau und das ist
natürlich der das würde ich sagen ist
der alles entscheidende unterschied wenn
man zu der situation die wir jetzt haben
er dem virus ist das völlig wurscht wenn
wir uns ihm mutig entgegen stellen und
sagen hier virus du fürchtest unsere
michael sagte er wir uns genau weil er
mich das boot nicht ein
das ist vollkommen richtig und das muss
man in der tat auch sehr sehr sauber
auseinander halten und darf nicht in
einen topf werfen trotzdem bleibt für
mich unter dem strich eine frage eben
also das ist eine frage an der johanna
auch viele lechte herum kaut ist es
nicht trotzdem wenn man so will auch ein
verrat an freiheit an an diesem
freiheits bedürfnis wenn man sagt man
ist ebenso sehr bereit freiheit auf
unbestimmte das ist ja das nächste
problem das ja auch völlig unklar ist
auch wie viel zeit wir jetzt diese
freiheitsrechte also ich bin überhaupt
keine die irgendein satz von denen
unterschreiben würde die sagen ja ja wir
haben ja jetzt schon die diktatur
eigentlich für groben unfug
aber natürlich bleibt eine frage wann
ist eine demokratie eine freiheitlich
verfassten gesellschaft beschädigt wenn
die freiheitsrechte ins tiefkühlfach auf
unabsehbare zeit gelegt werden weil man
sagt wir haben ja allerbeste gründe wir
haben jetzt eine durchhalten rhetorik
aber die ist unbestimmt man weiß nicht
so genau genau wann und das kann auch
niemand verantwortlich sagen dass diese
situation jeder der sagt also wir haben
keine ahnung nicht dann gesagt wohin so
ein virus mutiert es kann alles gut
werden kann alles auch noch viel
schlimmer werden und da stört mich auch
wenn wir nochmal auf öffentliche
rhetorischen kommen diese rhetorik diese
des lockout locked down durchhaltens war
ja doch sehr geknüpft an eine quasi
mechanische rhetorik um die rund um den
impfstoff
was aber auch sehr vernünftig war zu
sagen also wir haben jetzt weil sie heiß
horizont wir haben die superwaffe weil
sie den messias gegen dieses virus der
wird kommen und bis dahin halten wir
jetzt wahnsinnig tapfer durch wenn jetzt
aber verdachtsmomente auftauchen dass
diese impfungen wie sie ja für
politische entscheidungen zumindest in
deutschland durchaus relevant gerade
sind dass man den sinkenden
infektionszahlen nicht traut wenn man
sagt da sind aber diese gefährliche
mutanten am horizont und im
allerschlimmsten fall ist da der
impfstoff gar nicht mehr richtig wirksam
dann verliert ja aber die locker und
begründung die immer quasi beschränkt
war bis auf die ankunft des ministers in
gestalt des impfstoff gewissermaßen
sicher ihre legitimität und darüber
würde ich gerne eine große öffentliche
debatte haben anstatt zu sagen na ja
jetzt verhalten wir noch mal drei wochen
durch wie gesagt ich glaube man kann
immer nur dieses berühmte auf sicht
fahren ist wahrscheinlich es geht
momentan nicht anders weil wir eben alle
nicht wirklich sicher in die zukunft
gucken können aber dass dies das
auszuhalten und daran nicht ihre zu
werden das ist ja auch eine frauen von
reife wenn man die situation in ihrer
komplexität es gibt die politischen
aspekte es gibt aber auch die
existentiellen wie geht man denn mit
dieser trostlosen situation und ihre
johanna stürzt sich dann in einer sehr
wilden nacht in eine art orgie
anders gesagt eine form ist ihre wollte
ist der exzess ist die feier des lebens
in all seinen zügen und wenn ich dann
sterbe dann habe ich wenigstens
intensive gelebt ein beispiel dafür ist
auch eine postkarte die gesendet wird
das ist ein bild von judith leister
einer malerin aus dem 17 jahrhundert und
sie nennen das einen flotten vanitas
dreier schultheiß der letzte tropfen da
geht es genau darum dass man gerade weil
man endlich er sagt jetzt haben wir noch
mal auf die pauke weil das ist das was
das leben eigentlich ausmacht ja das ist
finde ich eine legitime handlung also
ich finde es schwierig die per se als
verantwortungslos darf man überhaupt
nicht darüber diskutieren weg zu
diskreditieren
diese haltung hat die menschen probleme
ja wohl unter sicherheitsgesichtspunkten
also man könnte sagen wenn ihr das für
euch macht ist das gut aber genau die
option gibt es ja im moment nicht
deshalb stecken wir mitten in einer
tragödie weil alles wo man der 1
recht gibt tut man der anderen seite
unrecht aber eben das ist das
kennzeichen einer tragischen situation
das aber nicht dadurch besser wird dass
man die ansprüche die bedürfnisse die
wert empfindungen die lebens vorstellung
der einen seite eben immer nur
disqualifiziert als reißt euch zusammen
ihr seid unvernünftig ihr seid
verantwortungslos die frage ist ob es
formen geben kann mit diesen entweder
diesen unversöhnlichen rest den man auf
der anderen seite produziert besser
umzugehen als dem immer nur zu sagen die
ungezogenen kindern jetzt weißt du dich
mal zusammen und benehmt euch holen sie
glauben das ist eine aufgabe von
philosophen wäre ein gespräch dieser
frau mann zu landen
unbedingt was wären die holzland ich
glaube dass in dem fall sind es
tatsächlich relativ verwandten
disziplinen zu sagen doch also eben ich
finde es ganz problematisch dass zum
beispiel die kunst momentan unter den
sektor zu nagelstudio sportstudio
subsumiert also auch im sport kann man
trost finden und kann dampf ablassen
auch ein wichtiger sublimieren faktor
für dinge die aufgestaut werden und dass
sich aber keiner so richtig fragt wo
soll denn das hin was wir eben an
dunklen an schwarzen emotionen gerade
produzieren und ich will jetzt überhaupt
nicht keiner weise das empfehlen
politisch was meine johanna treibt sagen
leute ok dann lasst es krachen lassen
wobei machen wir uns auch nichts vor
also gerade in der stadt wie berlin habe
ich den eindruck die prohibition also
das was man kriegt man prohibition
verordnet ist blüht ein interessantes
untergrund leben an allen fronten so und
das wird auch glaube ich nicht weniger
aber fordern sie sagten
einerseits ist es schädlich dass die
künste zu sagen wir etwas
nebensächliches behandelt werden ist die
kehrseite dieser diagnose nicht dass es
genauso schädlich ist dass die künste
sich derzeit als systemrelevant
generieren wollen und gerade eine
stabilisierung im system hervorrufen
wollen für die künstler nun gerade nicht
zuständig sein
ok jetzt müssen wir den begriff systemen
ist endlich ein sehr schöner behandelt
uns nicht wichtig genug und dann sagen
die anderen wir sind doch systemrelevant
und mir scheint aus theologischer sich
das ist ein furchtbarer gibt begriff für
die künste ist gar nicht alles themen
relevant ist ein furchtbares
griff würde also dann da muss dann
müsste ich gerne einmal bitte definiert
haben was das system ist ist es unser
freiheitlicher rechtsstaat ist es unsere
soziale marktwirtschaft also was genau
ist das system da ich das schon nicht
wirklich weiß bisher keiner erklärt hat
was er meint ist es auch schwer zu sagen
was ist relevant für dieses system also
gerade ein land wie deutschland was
keine sonntagsrede kein politiker lässt
es aus darauf hinzuweisen dass man ja
irgendwie noch das ganze kulturen in der
stadt genau die gleiche situation hat
man alles im gepäck
und da muss ich schon sagen also da
glaube ich auch dass mir das in den
nächsten jahren so ist denn wieder dazu
kommt schon schwer fallen wird ein
politiker noch eine sonntagsrede in
irgend einem museum oder in einer oper
abzukaufen wo er sagt wie wahnsinnig
systemrelevant um nicht so die kunst
dort sei aber ist man sich genauso wenn
sie die ganze zeit jetzt klagen wie ihre
systemrelevant sie sind es wird mir
wahnsinnig schwer fallen irgendeinem
theatermacher noch abzunehmen dass er ja
eigentlich wahnsinnig subversiv sein
werden aber damit jetzt mal wieder bei
einer weile würden wir quasi den
heroischen theatermacher der sagt mir
ist das alles wurscht start
ihr könnt mir noch so viele ich mache
heute abend ich schade die tapferen
unerschrockenen aus meinem haus bauen
will um mit bei mir geht heute abend der
lappen hoch im theater ich rufe alles
publikum auf kommt heute abend das wäre
quasi ein widerstand akt würden wir da
auch sagen das ist ungefähr so heroisch
wie das was ja navalny tod oder will
sagen das ist ein corona leutner spieler
man würde sicher je nach inszenierung
sich fragen müssen was die funktion
dieser intervention ist ich könnte mir
schon vorstellen dass es formen der
kunst jetzt gibt die sagen nein die
funktion ist genau auf diese
abgründigkeit hinzuweisen
vielleicht auch in offener und vernunft
ist doch eine funktion der kunst löcher
in unser vernünftige mitzureißen und zu
sagen wir machen jetzt nicht mit ja also
deshalb finde ich es zum beispiel gerade
für die darstellenden künste die nun
wirklich vom unmittelbaren austausch von
dass man wie viele menschen im selben
raum dass man den atem der anderen hört
dass man den schweiß spritzen sieht
manchmal auch recht was da von der bühne
herunter kommt dass das halt jetzt
irgendwie so also nichts gegen streamen
und das ist ja auch alles wunderbar wenn
sagen überhaupt stattfinden können und
daneben
gestreamt werden aber das ist natürlich
das hat nichts mehr mit dem zu tun auch
mit dem theater hat natürlich auch ein
anarchisches potenzial also das hat
literatur auch und in einer gewissen
weise bin ich aber auch schauspielerin
wenn ich so ein roman schreibe ich gehe
dann so wie ein schauspieler in seine zu
mir nach auffassung also die
schauspieler die wirklichen ihre rollen
schlüpfen und für 12 34 stunden dann
hamlet oder richard den dritten oder
wenn es ganz schlimm läuft mephisto sind
das geht mir beim schreiben ähnlich ich
sitze da nicht thomas mann distanz da
unfälle die figuren in ein plot und
sonntag da rein und mit ich schmeiße
mich also im schauspiel würde man sagen
das ist sozusagen lee strassberg methode
also ich schmeiß mich wirklich in diese
figuren rein und braucht dann auch immer
eine gewisse zeit bis sich daraus wieder
auftauche und das hat natürlich was
anarchisch ist das ist wenn man so will
das paradox eines kontrollierten
anarchisch seien gefolgt die immer noch
regeln
es ist ja nun nicht einfach nur pardon
die sau raus lassen sondern es hat ja
immer noch regen darin also ist es
müssen vollständige sätze seien die
schauspieler auf der bühne bleiben in
ihren rollen wissen in der regel waren
die form ist noch da genau und das ist
ein solcher schaden und ein solcher
verlust dass gerade jetzt wo wir das so
dringend bräuchten und das alles fehlt
und sie haben schon recht das ist
natürlich nicht nur die politik dies
verbietet sondern es wird auch also
glaubten in deutschland hat einer
bürgerwehr
also in einem interview hat frank
castorf galt daraufhin aber als
unmöglich der hatte im frühjahr
vergangenen jahres einen sehr wütend
gesetzlichen rente liegt mein berühmter
genauem berühmter der deutsche
theaterregisseur der aus der ehemaligen
ddr stammen und da auch nicht ganz
beliebt war sagen was man so also einer
der sich durchaus auch mit systemen
gerne mal angelegt hat der sich auch
jetzt mit diesem system anlegte und
sagen wir mal so es ist diejenigen die
sagten mensch da explodiert endlich mal
ein künstler und sagt ich will kunst
machen die stimmen waren nicht sehr laut
im wesentlichen galt casdorff als was
habe ich gehört kaspar clown macht sich
lächerlich aber es war dann leicht eine
ecke gedrängt auch die sagten ja dieses
dialogische den ansprechpartner haben
dass es im denken wie im schreiben sehr
wichtig nicht jeder kann ein buch
schreiben nicht jeder kann sich auf
diese weise trösten dass es in eine
andere person rein denkt und es
formuliert aber jeder kann doch zum
beispiel lesen wo wir jetzt zum ende des
gesprächs kommen was ist ja zum beispiel
der philosoph an den sie sich wenden
wenn sie trost haben wollen bei mir wäre
es zum beispiel der video weil ich denke
das ist ein philosoph der einem mit
dieser weisheit sehr sehr viel
vermitteln kann
gibt es denn ein philosoph wurde sagt
auf den fall ich immer wieder zurück in
den stunden der dunkelheit
es ist eigentlich er dann schon die
literatur also ganz vorne weg ist es für
mich auch musik also wenn ich ganz akut
trost bedürftig bin hilft nur noch
schuberts winterreise das ist mein mein
trost schlechthin
kurz bevor dicht gefolgt von andreas
gryphius und seinen großartigen vanitas
gedichten du siehst wohin du siehst nur
einigkeit auf erden was dieser heute
baut reißt jeden morgen ein und so
weiter also dieser also aus einem gefühl
der verlassenheit der verzweiflung was
so schön ist mit worten machen zu können
finde ich immens tröstlich das ist
tatsächlich für mich eineinhalb bei
philosophen erscheint mir
interessanterweise eigentlich alle
tröstlich die ich nicht dogmatisch auf
der höhe des problems empfinde
also da zu einer der tödlichsten lag
eine der köstlichsten lektüren für mich
im lockdown philosophische marquardt den
ich sträflich vernachlässigt hatte
vorher und der mir mit seinem
unglaublich sympathischen realismus
anbietet toleranz um jeden preis
ausreichen
juni waren ironie fähig genau auch ein
eleganter stilist muss man auch erwähnen
der den habe ich ihm mensch gerne
gelesen in den monaten das lock down
also viel lieber als zum beispiel einen
seneca der mir eben austauschen besser
wissen heraus punkt eins bis zehn
erklärt wie ich mich zu verhalten habe
das tröstet mich gar nicht habe ich
gemerkt haben macht mich eher wütend
wenn ich das lese aber ein auto
marquardt der so klug auf die schwierige
kommunizieren eingeht und die nicht
versucht in irgendeine richtung zu gehen
oder zu stoßen oder abgehoben sondern
sagt mensch wir setzen uns gemeinsam
bieten und denken darüber nach was für
ein schlamassel ist mensch zu sein
das finde ich ziemlich tröstlich was für
ein schlamassel ist ist noch mensch zu
sein dabei gelenkig zu bleiben und das
sehen zu wollen das ist die aufgabe
tröstliche gedanken heute von ihnen
vielen dank dafür ich denke sie an und
nächste woche spricht barbara bleisch
mit dem philosophen und physiker klaus
bei smart über die grenzen des wissens
und darüber warum es nicht stimmt dass
wir wissen dass wir nichts wissen
und jetzt gleich fragt die sternstunde
kunst wie schützt man kultur und kunst
vor krieg und zerstörung ein film über
wertvolle fotografien aus gaza und ein
gespräch über kulturgüterschutz in
krisengebieten bleiben sie also dran
trösten sie sich und denken sie weiter
[Musik]